a casi 10 meses del inicio de la
operación rusa en Ucrania Vladimir Putin
encabezó una Cumbre militar donde
reiteró el futuro éxito de sus tropas en
el este europeo Pese a que en las
últimas semanas han tenido que
retroceder ante la contraofensiva
ucraniana
es sabido que se está utilizando el
potencial militar y las capacidades de
casi todos los principales países de la
otan pero nuestros soldados sargentos y
oficiales están luchando por Rusia con
valentía y resistencia están logrando
sus objetivos poco a poco y sin duda
todos estos objetivos se lograrán en
todos los territorios rusos
en su discurso el líder ruso resaltó que
los comandantes deben aprovechar la
situación para desarrollar mejoras en la
capacidad vérica y recalcó la puerta del
gobierno a las necesidades militares
no tenemos restricciones financieras el
país el gobierno da todo lo que pide el
ejército todo Espero que la respuesta se
formule adecuadamente y se logren los
resultados correspondientes
tras la palabra el presidente compareció
el ministro de defensa sergible el
funcionario expuso la intención de
aumentar la cantidad de tropas un 30% y
elevar la edad de reclutamiento además
informó que planean instalar puertos en
los territorios capturados como las
ciudades de y maripol y las regiones de
danés y saporilla
la tarea prioritaria para el 2023 es
continuar con la operación militar
especial hasta completar los objetivos
esta Cumbre sucede al mismo tiempo que
el presidente ucraniano volodinski
adelanta en Estados Unidos una visita de
estado en busca de mayor apoyo
financiero y de